Я займаюся художньою обробкою металу.
У мене це мідь, латунь, мельхіор,
поєднання цих металів.
Художня обробка металу.
Так, беру оце от стільки спирту,
кладу візерунком.
Дідусь у мене різьбив,
прадід різьбив.
Мама — вчителька музики,
тато малює з дитинства.
Життя в такому середовищі,
напевно, і сприяло цьому.
Ну, тобто мені замість колискової грали
Моцарта або Бетховена на фортепіано.
Добре, готово.
Тут праску.
Добре, так.
Коли я вступив у Косівський інститут
і потрапив у середовище художнє, творче,
де люди вчаться різних ремесел.
І там я вперше побачив живого ювеліра.
Тобто до того для мене, в моїй голові,
ювеліри були десь там,
на невідомих заводах,
і прикраси в магазинах брали.
А тут я побачив людину,
яка реально робить прикраси.
Я побачив і захотів.
Просто одержую
цей малюнок на металі.
Через те, що лазерний друк...
Фарба з чого, зі свинцю?
А свинець — легкоплавкий метал.
Спирт відпускає його,
при температурах їх сплавлює і все.
Це мені дає змогу...
Він ніби переноситься на метал,
і [це] точність лінії,
по якій я пиляю.
Ось у мене навіть [виходить] малюнок.
Я беру свій старенький покоцаний лобзик.
У мене майстерня починалася з лобзика.
У мене якимось чином між цим
усім інструментом від діда
виявився старий австрійський лобзик.
Старий австрійський лобзик, у принципі,
вирішив мою художню долю.
Тому що це серйозний інструмент.
Ми закріпимо пилочку.
Я завжди хотів того.
Мені здавалося, що:
«О, художник — це мрія!».
Я часто бував у Львові,
і то тепер уже більше галерей всіляких,
більше якихось артоб'єктів.
А тоді була що?
Була «Дзиґа».
І приходиш, а там Денисенка [Олега Денисенка,
українського художника і скульптора] виставка.
І такий: «Вау, я теж так хочу!».
Не саме те, що він робить.
Я теж хочу вміти щось творити,
щось створювати, щось віддавати.
А коли вже відбувся в мене
контакт з металом,
і я почув, побачив,
що воно віддає, що воно виходить,
я сам для себе, насправді, відкрив,
що я — художник.
І все, я починаю пиляти.
Я роблю хрестики, я роблю зґарди
[обереги у вигляді хреста].
Тобто це вже такі прикраси,
в яких є кілька хрестиків і ланцюжки.
Роблю ланцюжки, роблю персні,
роблю сережки.
Майже весь набір.
Мета моєї творчості — осучаснити традицію,
збудувати місток між учора і сьогодні.
Осучаснювати її.
Приносити її не тільки
на вечірки з вишиванками,
а приносити її і в офіси.
Я мрію, щоби...
Ну, знаєш, мені здається,
що коли от люди їдуть за кордон звідси,
у них є якийсь ніби комплекс неповноцінності.
Бо штани від одного бренду,
шузи — від іншого бренду.
Я хочу, щоб, нехай,
були шузи гарні від одного бренду,
джинси і, ну, там весь лук
був від бренду,
але прикраси були українськими.
Щоб найдорогоцінніше було українським.
От я би хотів, щоб воно було
не тільки українським, а від мене.
Щоби бренд мій був
одним із таких артмаркерів у світі.
Все, в результаті ми одержуємо...
Гаразд, все, тоді це у мене
йде у відходи,
і починається наступний етап.
Це був найлегший.
[сміється]
Мені треба всі площини почистити.
Я беру надфіль [найдрібніший напилок],
починаю зачищати.
Я собі чищу,
куди мені там рівно треба.
Я просто розумію:
якщо люди повертаються до тих джерел,
з яких вони вийшли,
я відчуваю,
що цей поклик живий,
і його просто треба годувати, плекати.
Плекати таку гордість за те,
звідки ти вийшов,
за те, ким ти є,
за те, що ти українець,
за те, що ти належиш цій землі,
за те, що ти належиш
цьому культурному коду.
І якщо...
Дуже приємно,
коли цього хочуть молоді,
тому що вони насамперед для себе
переосмислили свою ідентифікацію.
А я тільки їм даю предмети,
які підтверджують їхню ідентифікацію.
Карпати і Прикарпаття.
Це Полісся і Волинь.
Це Південна Україна.
Це Слобожанщина.
Це Центральна Наддніпрянщина.
Це Поділля.
І це Волинь.
Та робота називається «Єдина країна».
Це коли війна почалася,
мене теж «плющило».
Дерево життя зображають в усіх історико...
Усюди є дерево життя як символ.
Але я побачив, помітив,
що в кожному регіоні його
якось по-своєму зображають.
Я подумав, що класно...
Мені довелося, звичайно, узагальнити.
Я вирізнив сім історико-етнографічних
регіонів України,
дослідив матеріал:
це з вишиванки, різьби по дереву,
кераміки.
Все, що я знайшов,
де зображалося дерево життя.
Я подивився, яке воно,
ми це все вималювали нормально,
виділили щось конкретно,
потім перенесли в метал,
і вийшла така серія.
Головна ідея — ми всі, може,
не такі вже й однакові,
але ми всі є однією країною,
тому що у нас одне дерево життя.
Воно може відрізнятись з вигляду,
але всюди воно є деревом нашого життя.
Це єдина країна.
Я тоді починаю прокладати чисто дно,
щоби тут боки починати прорізати.
По суті, я починаю різьбити.
Так, як дід різьбив по дереву,
так я просто починаю різьбити по металу.
Україна для мене особисто —
це земля, на якій я народився,
це культура,
це історія.
Це не тільки те, що...
Це не тільки ресурси,
це ще й душа.
Україна — це душа.
І моя душа є частиною,
належить моїй країні.
І Богу.
Бог і Україна.